hey everybody you are watching the game
spot.com at newsroom stage at e3 2015
I'm Alexa ray and I'm here with one of
my favorite people Michael that's very
kind thank you and we're going to play
his awesome game coming out soon August
eighteenth that's prolly yes it's a
stealth game it's kind of a pure stealth
it's the it's it's all the all the stuff
all the cool gadgets all the cool gizmos
for avoiding enemies that you never use
because you've got the gun and guns just
overpower everything so it's trying to
focus in on that back or stealth using
gadgets using the environment using the
enemies kind of patrols against them and
stuff oh so I want to show you something
from a bit later in the game now I think
because i'm showing i'm showing kind of
the same few levels to a lot of people
kind of doing it quite straightforward
stuff i want to show you something from
a little bit later a little bit more a
little bit harder Oh which is why I'm
driving um yes i will die like this is
the thing like because of the pressure
because there's a camera i will die a
lot pressure it's gonna be fine though
this is the judges keep so the judge is
a horrible man he's he's giving a lot of
power to the bad guys he is one of the
worst of these people and i'm going to
die immediately oh good start oh this is
this is this is a one of his uh his
businesses i think but the AI is very
creative your help by this character
Alan um and he likes to show off so this
level I believe he is made to look like
a car still for his own amusement um
that's how he rolls so what I'm going to
do is I'm gonna get through it so as you
can see here I'm kind of hidden down in
the bottom waiting for these patrolling
guards I'm going to just cut across here
now the vision cones in this game are
absolutely honest so as long as you stay
other vision cones you can get as close
as you like to them um we didn't want
any ambiguity we don't want you to not
know where an enemy is looking we don't
want you to ever feel that you don't
have all of the information because the
second floor like that that's where the
game starts feel like it's cheating yeah
as you'll see there i'm kind of using
the dodging and weaving and I should get
past all of these guards now this guy is
patrolling back and Paul quite tense
let's try let's go here
hopping to cover here it's we really
trying to make it as smooth as possible
so any and you snap quickly into cover
and you can move around cover matically
as well I've noticed that really
important here I like I don't know like
big like like I'm covering in like a
really long amazing yeah it's it's
awesome and it and on it was something
that we had some good news for this we
have quite long animation in there
originally and yet we have that problem
there was like you were just you were
watching an animation playing at the
worst moment so what we do is we make a
really split there's a few frames of
animation there there's a little a
little thicker but what we do is we do
it with sound so we have some some kind
of noises there which we can sell the
movement even though you're moving
faster than is humanly possible video
games right um video games let's go oh
man you're pro at this well I mean you
mean I play again I play up every now
and again yeah so here I have a gadget
now gadgets Accord to this game so
you're going to find these around the
levels you don't take them with you
they're embedded in the environment okay
however when you find one it changes up
a gameplay i am in massive labels to be
seen here oh I stunned him at the exact
moment he killed me oh is that what the
black juice right so blackjack is a
stunt we don't have any weapons in the
game we don't have any ability for you
to permanently remove an enemy and all
you knock them out permanently in the
Batman sense but what we can do is we
have these gadgets that kind of will
have a very short-term effect so this is
the blackjack here you can see it's got
a bit of an auto lock on it what it'll
do is it'll knock out an enemy for a few
seconds just enough to get past them
he'll wake up very soon oh I like that
it's just it's always it's a panic
button in a lot of ways it's just a very
quick way out I can now get back out
here deactivate this force field and I
can get back to where I started but this
time I'm armed so now i can get into
this into this castle in the middle of
the map and you can use Oh nobody seemed
OBC oh you JK that's okay I go away
that's the other thing is we don't want
to I don't we don't want being seen to
be the end of the game so as long as you
can move around quickly you can actually
get out those situations that plays when
you're seeing waiting like sort of
crescendos and we have this we have like
David's back you did the music
was alone and like I'm biased but he's
just taken his game up so so far we've
got you know grey kind of recorded live
music for the game and I'm gonna die
here because I'm too busy showing off
it's all right though because of our
friendly checkpointing system ah so so
yeah and we got you know an opera singer
doing the vocals we've got the whole
works and it's it's great he able to
play with those toys and really that is
that's because of the audience that's
because a few years ago bunch of people
bought again by rectangles I get to play
with these things and I feel so it's so
lucky so lucky and privileged to
actually have the opportunity to to play
with these toys and to make games using
them so I'm going to go in here I'm not
going to use my black Jones no need to
her these guys they just trying to do a
day's work work my way around here
linkedin a paycheck exactly get into
this central room here oh wow collect
all of that coins there's one more ya go
no way because of that you can see that
pulse now that means an axe it's opened
up for us which we can get to so let's
do so i looked at the visual cues are
very subtle like like there's an exit
door is just a very it's just a line
like I love it sort of it's that amount
he saw me but I go away with it I kind
of went out a bit hop i will show you
something else got a little bit of time
if that's okay yes i'll show you the
editor yes show me the editor right
exciting so the editor this is what this
is how we make it so that this game can
live on for a while like it's a it's a
substantial game I'm not saying how many
hours because I get told off if I say
how about now it's a lot of hours Oh
many hours some hours so what we do is
we extend this by making you able to
create your own experiences oh wow so
this is this is the tool we used we
don't have a secret better level editor
this is the level editor that we use so
anything you see in the game can be made
in this it's it's like using paint brush
your drawing up these rules and objects
so that's a wall there I can then use
these sliders to have color those are
nice I'm a nerd so I can do some clever
lighting and oh and the only rule we
have is in order to make a level you
need a level target so put on down here
and then you can just play it now
admittedly that's not a fun level that's
going to be quite an easy level so we
can
actually make that actually have some
gameplay so we can go okay so I want
that to be unlocked with some gems so
let's yeah now you don't have to do any
logic you don't have to be doing any
script or anything the game works out so
if I play some gems down here it will
automatically know not to make the exit
work and to load collecting all of them
so it's doing a lot of clever stuff
behind the scenes to build a level for
you Wow and we take that on further so
with the NBC's for example the enemies
in the game I can place one down I can
have him looking up the screen I can
click oh there we go hi and I can have
him do a patrol back and forth now you
can see his pulse laying out there I
could choose where he looks when he's
there how long he stays there are saying
I'm sorry you can change the type it
says tape yeah oh yes notice that you've
noticed that people got some good game
journalism right there heck yeah that's
why thats I yes I can make him a sniper
that dog talk it's yeah sorry Triple A
game let's do this it's a dog but now
that doesn't actually hurt you but he's
got amazing vision comb that he will
bark and see you and come hunting for
you let's make him into something else
cuz i love the music he's really good
isn't it so he the dog so yes so we have
all of that we have we can even we even
have Instagram filters so if you want
like saturate the color and mess around
with it that's available to you too so
yeah so Augustine that's when we get our
hands on volume that's right yeah
playstation 4 vita pc and mac all da
nova stay tuned excellent thank you so
much for taking time out of your show to
come show us i was awesome lots of fun
yeah that was awesome everybody else
tune in to gamespot com for all of your
III news